Another example of prefetching would
be the so-called Hardware Prefetching.
Where the program doesn't change,
and the hardware itself, either
the processor or the cache is trying
to guess what will be accessed soon.
There are a number of harder
prefetchers that work reasonably well.
For example,
many current processors include what's
called a Stream Buffer prefetcher.
Other popular types of prefetchers
include a Stride Prefetcher and
what is called a Correlating Prefetcher.
All of these try to guess what
is going to be accessed next
based on some sort of locality property.
So a Stream Buffer is
sequential in nature.
It's trying to see whether
once we access a blog and
then the next block that follows it.
We are likely to access
the next next block and so on.
So it's just trying to fetch
several blocks in advance
in order to not be too late.
A stride based prefetcher is
monitoring accesses to see if memory
accesses we are doing, are at
the fixed distance from each other.
So if their addresses
differ by the same amount.
It's going to guess,
that we will just continue doing that.
And it starts prefetching with
the distance of D times something.
And it determines how
many of these in advance.
Such that it's just in time.
A Correlating Prefetcher is
trying to predict sequences
of accesses that are not sequential or
at the same distance from each other.
The way it does this is when
we see A and B accessed,
it remembers in some sort of a table
that, when A comes then B comes.
Then when C comes it remembers
that after B comes C and so on.
And then later on if we see A,
it's going to look here and
issue prefetch for B.
If we do access B it's going to
look here and issue a prefetch for
C and so on.
So it can prefetch an arbitrary
sequence of accesses
as long as that sequence repeats.
So it's very good for example for
linklist which are not necessarily
sequential in memory and
are not at fixed strides, but
if you access the first note, then
the second or third note and you do it
again, it's going to prefetch correctly.